jetzt gibt es gleich zwei neue studien
die belegen sollen wie sauber
elektrische fahrzeuge tatsächlich sind
also sind sie es oder nicht ihre
ökobilanz hängt nämlich maßgeblich von
zwei faktoren ab und im besten fall gibt
es nur ein einziges fahrzeug an dass die
individuelle autos in puncto emissionen
nicht herankam am ende des videos gibt's
übrigens ein tool mit dem man die co2
bilanz selbst für jedes auto berechnen
kann krieg zum 21 11 user gibt es
regelmäßig umfassend recherchierte
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's haben sie
willkommen klingt so gibt es übrigens
jetzt auch als podcast für alle die zum
beispiel im auto unterwegs sind die
links spotify und apple podcasts sind
unten in der video beschreibung der
verkehr ist hierzulande die drittgrößte
co2 quelle direkt nach der
energieerzeugung und der industrie die
emissionen aus dem verkehr liegen bei
über 165 millionen tonnen co2 pro jahr
und der größte teil davon stammt aus dem
individualverkehr auf den straßen
vor diesem hintergrund wird einem
bewusst welche bedeutung die entwicklung
der elektromobilität für das klima hat
und da muss man dieses mal eine lanze
für die bundesregierung brechen das
konjunkturpaket in dem ausschließlich
die förderung von e-autos enthalten ist
ist tatsächlich so sehr vernünftig die
politik hat dem absurden werben der
autoindustrie um die förderung von
verbrennungsmotoren widerstanden und
dieses mal hieß es nicht das war das
machbare wie beim klima paket was ja
eine ziemliche katastrophe war aber
warum ist genau das richtig die
förderung von elektroautos in der
jüngeren vergangenheit gab es immer
wieder meldungen zu schlechten
ökobilanzen von elektroautos ganz
besonders die bekannte schwedische
studie die sorgte 2017 für aufsehen denn
sie war ein gefundenes fressen für alle
gegner der elektromobilität sie gab an
dass ein elektrofahrzeug kaum
umweltfreundlicher wäre als ein
sparsamer diesel oder benziner und in
den medien kursierte sogar ein wert von
17,5 tonnen co2 den die produktion eines
e auto akkus angeblich verursachen würde
dieser wert wurde aber in der studie
setzt gar nicht genannt sondern von
einem schwedischen sondern
in den umlauf gebracht der sich auf ein
tesla model s mit einer kapazität von
100 kilowattstunden bezogen also nicht
gerade ein durchschnittliches
elektroauto das als maßstab dienen kann
das verheerende ergebnis der studie
wurde aber längst korrigiert sie basiert
auf veralteten basisdaten und wurde neu
berechnet dabei zeigte sich dass die e
autos nur halb so klimaschädlich sind
wie ursprünglich angenommen und nochmal
die einschränkung laut dieser studie
aber immerhin es gibt eben auch immer
wieder neue studien die die positiven
ökobilanz der elektrisch angetriebene
fahrzeuge belegen eine davon wurde jetzt
von transport and environment
herausgegeben einem europaweiten
zusammenschluss nichtstaatlicher
organisationen der sich dem thema
nachhaltiger mobilität widmet für den
deutschen mitgliedern gehören unter
anderem der verkehrsclub deutschland und
der nato
der deutsche naturschutzbund diese neue
studie zeichnet und sie ist wirklich
sehr umfangreich und detailliert
ebenfalls ein durchweg positives bild
der ökobilanz von elektroautos sie
basiert auf den neuesten erkenntnissen
und daten die zeigen dass ein
durchschnittliches elektroauto in der eu
schon heute fast drei mal
umweltfreundlicher ist als ein
vergleichbares konventionelles auto
interessant dass elektroautos immer
umweltfreundlicher werden zum einen
liegt das wohl an den immer besseren
datengrundlagen da wird der transport
des erdöl aus dem förderländern zum
beispiel nicht vergessen und so weiter
und so fort aber auch die batterien
werden immer effizienter und das hat
folgen aber wie kann es bei solchen
daten eigentlich sein dass es immer noch
meldungen gibt in denen von einer
schlechten umwelt bilanz der stromer die
rede ist oftmals greifen forschende auf
veraltete daten zurück und vergleichen
diese schnell entwickelten den
elektroautos mit ausgereifter benzin
oder diesel technologie die wenig
spielraum verbesserung hat und sich
künftig sogar verschlechtern könnte
manche lebenszyklusanalyse sind sogar
absichtlich irreführend und na ja wir
wissen vom diesel betrug und wenn man
darauf basierende daten vergleicht ja
wenn man wirklich wissen will welche
fahrzeuge in der ökobilanz am besten
abschneiden muss man sich umfassende
daten anschauen die nicht nur die co2
emissionen am auspuff betrachten man
benötigt einen ganzheitlichen blick
inklusive der strombereitstellung für
den laufenden betrieb und
der herstellung des autos besonders auch
der antriebs batterienhersteller daten
und werbeprospekten wird man diese werte
aus der produktion und dem
alltagsbetrieb nicht finden deshalb sind
umfangreiche studien wie die von
transport and environment so wichtig die
gute nachricht daran schneiden die
elektrischen fahrzeuge in allen
szenarien besser ab als ihre konkurrenz
mit verbrennungsmotoren allerdings hängt
ihre ökobilanz von einigen faktoren ab
und variiert je nach produktionsstart
größe des wagens seiner lebensdauer und
übrigens dem land in dem das fahrzeug
gefahren wird wie sieht der energiemix
dort aus aber im durchschnitt stoßen die
elektroautos in europa fast dreimal
weniger co2 aus als entsprechende benzin
oder dieselautos das ist schon ein
hammer wert der erste entscheidende
faktor dafür wie gut ein e-auto
abschneidet ist der eingesetzte strommix
im produktionsland des akkus und
schließlich im absatzmarkt die methodik
der studie für die emissionen der
batterieherstellung stützt sich auf
aktualisierte kohlenstoff werte für das
stromnetz und basiert auf den
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen aus
neueren batterie anlagen das ist schon
lange bekannt dass besonders die akku
produktion sehr zäh und zwei intensiv
ist dabei fällt fast so viel co2 wie bei
der produktion des gesamten restlichen
fahrzeugs das land in dem der
energiespeicher produziert wird spielt
daher eine sehr wichtige rolle sein
strommix entscheidet über die co2 bilanz
des akkus und damit schließlich auch des
fertigen wagens in einem land wie
schweden in dem viel ökostrom im netz
ist schneidet die akku produktion gut ab
in china wo der strommix einen hohen
kohleanteil hat sieht es natürlich
deutlich schlechter aus noch mehr
emissionen als die produktion verursacht
je nach land das fahren eines
elektroautos das kann sogar ein
vielfaches der produktion seien und
damit ist der standort an dem ein
elektro auto gefahren wird noch
bedeutender für die gesamtbilanz als der
produktionsstandort dass akkus auch hier
steht schweden an erster stelle und am
schlechtesten schneidet polen ab aber
selbst dort performance e-autos trotz
des kohlenstoff intensiven netzes immer
noch etwa 30 prozent besser als
herkömmliche autos selbst im
schlechtesten fall wenn ein elektroauto
in polen gefahren wird und mit einer in
china hergestellten batterien
bestimmt ist sorgt es noch für 22
prozent weniger co2 als ein
vergleichbares dieselauto und 28 prozent
weniger als ein benziner im besten fall
in dem die akku produktion und auch die
ladevorgänge in schweden stattfinden
werden im vergleich zum diesel sogar 80
prozent und im vergleich zum benziner 81
prozent weniger co2 ausgestoßen
in deutschland stößt ein elektroauto 56
prozent weniger co2 aus als ein
verbrenner damit liegt die
bundesrepublik leicht unter dem
europäischen durchschnitt von 63 prozent
weniger co2 ein weiterer wichtiger
faktor im direktvergleich mit
konventionellen fahrzeugen ist die größe
eines autos große und schwere fahrzeuge
haben einen höheren energieverbrauch und
bei ihnen wird mit einem elektroantrieb
mehr co2 ausstoß vermieden als bei
kleineren autos das ist ein wichtiger
und entscheidender punkt viele
vergleichen äpfel mit würden man muss
große elektroautos auch mit großen wagen
mit verbrennungsmotoren vergleichen das
ist deshalb so relevant weil es den weit
verbreiteten gedanken von e-autos als
reine stadtautos entkräftet es ist also
sinnvoll nicht nur kleine cityflitzer
sondern besonders auch große autos
elektrisch anzutreiben auch wenn ein
größerer akku erst mal mehr emissionen
verursacht er sorgt aber dafür dass e
antriebe auch auf langen strecken
verbrennungsmotoren ablösen und sagst
bei fahrzeugen oft vergessen wird die
großen batterien haben die längere
lebensdauer die akkus müssen weniger
geladen werden also nicht so oft und
halten deshalb länger das testmodell es
schon heute zum beispiel eine million
kilometer der deutsche hans jörg
freiherr von gemmingen hornberg aus
baden stellte diesen rekord erstmals auf
der nächste bedeutende faktor ist
ebenfalls schon bekannt wird aber durch
die studie noch einmal deutlich
unterstrichen der faktor zeit dadurch
dass der strom in europa immer
nachhaltiger wird werden auch
elektroautos mit jedem jahr ein wenig
umweltfreundlicher verbrenner dagegen
werden im laufe der zeit nicht mehr
besser abschneiden schon jetzt mit 40
prozent fossil erzeugten strom sieht es
für elektroautos besser aus als für
benziner oder diesel in den nächsten 20
jahren soll der fossile anteil auf zehn
prozent sinken wodurch sich die
ökobilanz der stromer nochmal deutlich
verbessern wird mit dieser prognose und
der aktuell schon positiven bilanz steht
diese arbeit
nicht alleine da erst kürzlich hatte
eine studie der universitäten von
cambridge exeter und nun herausgefunden
dass das fahren eines elektroautos unter
aktuellen bedingungen schon in 95
prozent der welt klimafreundlicher ist
als das fahren eines benziners sogar in
kohle polen
beide studien betrachten vorrangig die
co2 emissionen weitere schadstoffe
werden außen vor gelassen um auch diese
mit einzubeziehen hat ein forschungsteam
des umweltcampus birkenfeld der
hochschule trier untersuchungen
angestellt in der regel basieren ja die
lebenszyklus analysen von e-autos auf
metadaten und es gibt kaum projekte mit
originären daten an der hochschule trier
wurde ein anderer ansatz gewählt um eine
vergleichende ökobilanz von autos mit
elektro- und verbrennungsantrieb
aufzustellen die bedingungen der
messungen kamen dem realen einsatz der
fahrzeuge dabei so nahe wie möglich für
die arbeit haben die forschenden
möglichst viele daten selbst erhoben und
dazu einen 1,6 liter benziner vw caddy
demontiert analysiert und mit einem
elektroantrieb wieder neu aufgebaut
dadurch konnten sie sehr detaillierte
daten erheben so gibt vw für den caddy
nur eine prozentuale aufteilung von neun
materialgruppen an aber nicht die
detaillierte zusammensetzung mit ihrer
analyse konnten die forschenden den
aufbau des verbrechers deutlich genauer
betrachten und sogar den transport der
einzelnen komponenten von ihren
produktionsstätten in salzgitter kassel
oder hannover bis zum werk in polen wo
der wagen gebaut wird nachvollziehen die
bilanz der produktion ist also sehr
genau auch in dieser studie lassen sich
der ergebnisse nicht auf einen einzelnen
wert oder eine einzelne abschließende
aussage fest gefallen ist gibt ja so ein
vw caddy gar nicht der genauso
ausgestattet ist wie ein verbrenner aber
trotzdem das prinzip ist schon mal sehr
interessant die vielen verschiedenen
faktoren machen mehrere szenarien
möglich zum beispiel bei der sogenannten
break even laufleistung also der
kilometerzahl ab der ein elektroauto in
der ökobilanz besser abschneidet als ein
verbrenner in best case wenn die 25
kilowattstunden große batterie des
umgebauten elektroautos mit windstrom
hergestellt wird und zur nutzung nur mit
ökostrom beladen wird erzielte schon
nach 17 tausend kilometern den break
even und ist sauberer als ein verbrenner
nimmt man aber ein fahrzeug mit einer
doppelt so großen batterie von 51
8 kilowattstunden die mit ökostrom
geladen wird kommt man schon auf 20.000
km
wenn sie mit windstrom produziert wurde
und auf ganze 35.000 kilometer wenn die
batterie mit kohlestrom hergestellt wird
kommt zum laden des autos statt ökostrom
der aktuelle mittelwert des europäischen
strommix es zum einsatz wird der break
even selbst bei der kleinen batterie
erst beim 50.000 kilometern erreicht im
worst case also bei einer großen
batterie mit 51,8 kilowattstunden die
mit kohlestrom hergestellt und mit einem
strom mix mit hohem fettanteil betrieben
wird müsste der wagen sogar ganze
310.000 kilometer laufen was aber bei
elektroautos mit ihrem wenigen
verschleißteilen nicht ungewöhnlich ist
selbst die bremsscheiben und beläge
müssen ja oft erst nach 200.000
kilometern erstmals ersetzt werden weil
die fahrzeuge meistens mit dem
elektromotor bremsen und strom aus ihrer
bewegungsenergie zurückgewinnen
rekuperieren auch die herstellung der
elektro variante des wagens kann sehr
unterschiedlich ausfallen
hier wurden vier szenarien für die
batterieproduktion modelliert eine
herstellung in china mit hohen
kohlestromanteil eine produktion in
europa mit dem europäischen strommix
eine fertigung mit 100 prozent
solarstrom wie sie in tesla speaker
factory nevada angewandt wird und eine
mit 100 prozent windstrom dies zwar
bisher noch nicht gibt aber ein
mögliches zukunftsszenario in europa
sein könnte die ergebnisse fallen
entsprechend unterschiedlich aus die
energiespeicher aus china kommen auf
1.000 180 gramm co2 äquivalent pro
kilowattstunde mit dem europäischen
strommix sind es nur noch 5 131 gramm
und die erneuerbaren energien erzielen
richtig gute werte mit solarstrom
entstehen 92 gramm co2 äquivalent pro
kilowattstunde mit windenergie sogar nur
15,8 gramm das bedeutet dass im
schlechtesten fall 36 prozent der
gesamten lebenszeit co2 emissionen eines
e autos allein durch die
batterieproduktion entstehen das ist
aber noch keinen hohen laufleistungen
berechnet worden vor diesem hintergrund
ist es eigentlich kaum zu glauben dass
die europäische gesetzgebung diese
herstellungs- emissionen immer noch
ignoriert bei dieser ganzheitlichen
betrachtung ist ein konzern wie tesla
der eu anscheinend schon weit voraus
tesla fliegen auf grund der
energieerzeugung für ihre fertigung
vor autos mit verbrennungsmotoren die
ausführliche studie betrachtet außerdem
noch weitere umweltauswirkungen
verglichen wird der benzinverbrauch von
8,8 9 litern auf 100 kilometern
vor dem umbau und der gemessene
stromverbrauch von 23,57 kilowattstunden
pro 100 kilometer nach dem umbau beides
übrigens nicht so tolle werte sehr hoch
beides neben der gesamten co2 bilanz
über eine lebensdauer von 150.000
kilometern wurden auch feinstaub
emissionen die ozon freisetzung oder die
erschöpfung der bodenschätze in
kilogramm eisen äquivalenten betrachtet
insgesamt unterteilt die studie die
ergebnisse in 18 kategorien und der
elektrifizierte caddy schneidet in
manchen nicht ganz so gut ab in fünf
kategorien ist er aber der klare sieger
beim klimawandel beim smog
bildungspotenzial beim abbau fossiler
ressourcen bei der natürlichen land
umwandlung und beim ozonabbau auch in
der gesamtbewertung aller faktoren
schneiden die elektroautos besser ab
hier machen die ergebnisse ebenfalls
deutlich dass die energiequellen für die
batterieproduktion und die ladung der
elektroautos die hauptfaktoren sind die
studie schließt du willst mit einem
interessanten vergleich ab die
zurückgelegten passagierkilometer werden
ebenfalls in verschiedenen szenarien mit
anderen verkehrsmitteln verglichen bei
optimalen bedingungen können die
auswirkungen des lebenszyklus von
elektroautos sogar mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln wie reisebussen oder
zügen mitteilten
das einzige motorisierte verkehrsmittel
an dass sie nicht herankommen ist der
elektrobus und die studie von transport
and environment bietet ebenfalls einen
spannenden zusatz die vorstände haben
mit ihren daten ein online tool
entwickelt dort kann jeder selbst ein
wenig mit den zahlen spielen und für
seinen eigenen fall die co2 bilanz eines
elektroautos brechen ihr findet das tool
über den link in der video beschreibung
probiert es mal aus ist es sehr spannend
die besten fünf elektroautos anklicken
anschauen und robin tv blau abonnieren
auf dem kanal geht es ausschließlich um
elektroautos also bis dann bleibt dran